xFS data structures for implementing a truly distributed
file system are much more involved. Let's talk
little bit about that, first of all, I
mentioned that the metadata management is not static. Even
though, the file that you are looking for
may be resident in particular node, the manager
for that file may not be at that same node. The client action when it is looking
for a file, it starts with a file name and this is a data structure that is
a replicated data structure at every node in
the entire distributed system. So any client node, when
it starts with a file name. It consults
this manager map data structure to know who's the
metadata manager for this particular file name. And the
manger node action is fairly involved. So, the client
comes to the manager with a file name. And
when you come to the manager with a file
name, the manager looks up the first data structure,
called the file directory. And that file directly has
the i-node number. And that i-node number is the
starting point for looking up the contents of that
file. Now let's talk about all the data structures
that are used by the manager node. On the
manager node, when the client presents the file
name, the manager node uses a data structure
called a file directory. To map that file
name to an i-number. And from the i-number, it
uses another data structure called i-map data structure
to get the i-note address for this particular file
name. The i-node address is the i-node address
for the log segment associated with this file name.
And using this strip group map, which is
telling. How this particular file is striped. It
can locate the storage server that contains the
log segment ID, that is associated with this
file name. I mentioned earlier, that every log
segment is actually striped on a whole bunch
of disks, a stripe group. What of the
stripe group associated with this particular log segment?
That's the information that it gets from the
stripe group map. Once it has the set of
storage servers that contain this log segment, it
can go to the set of storage servers to
get the data blocks associated with this particular
file name. That's the entire road map of what
the manager will have to do. To go from the file name to actual data blocks that
corresponds to that file name. Now this sounds
like a lot of work being done, fortunately caching
helps in making sure that this long path
is not taken for every file access. We will
see that, in terms of how reads and
writes happen. In the XFS file system. Just to
recap the data structures, file name to i-number mapping
is contained in this data structure, FileDir. The mapping
between the i-number and the i-node address for
the log segment ID, that is contained in
this i-map. Given the i-node address, I can
consult the stripe group map to know which storage
server actually has the i-node for this file
name that is a large segment that corresponds
to this file name. I can get that. And once I get that, then I can find
out the stripe group that is associated
with this log segment, and that'll say what
are all the storage servers that I have to contact in order to get the
contents of that log segment. Then I can go to those storage servers and get
all the data blocks that correspond to a
particular log segment. So that's the road map.